- It's December the 17th, 2020,
and I never thought that I would be here
at this place at this time in my life.
It was kind of rough
there for a moment, well,
longer than a moment.
And I'd like to start off this,
(sighs)
this topic as something that
happened to me last night.
I got up for work last night
and I paid my mom a visit
because it's been about three
months since I last seen her
but I talk to her almost every day.
And while I was in there,
and when I first got there,
I couldn't even hug her, man.
Because of her age, her condition,
the things she's going
through, she's working with.
She's got some health issues as she's 74,
I think 76 years old.
And I wanted to greet her
with a kiss on the forehead,
here, here, here, and on the lips
'cause that's how I greeted her
when I first came home from prison.
And I got that concept
from a book I was reading
and the book was,
the writer of the book said
her son had a best friend
whose father was an
alcoholic who lost his mom
when he was four years old
and his father was mean to him
and she knew his father
was mistreating him.
Not in the ways of physical
abuse but verbally.
He wasn't there for him
because he was always drunk.
So every time her son
would bring his best friend
over to the house,
she would greet him with
a kiss on the forehead,
the two left side cheeks and on the lips
and said, "I love you."
And when I read that,
I cried and I experienced that in prison.
That was like two and a
half years before parole.
I read that paragraph in that book
and two and a half years later,
when I was released from
motherfucking prison,
first place I went to was my mom's place.
I kissed her on the
forehead, both her cheeks,
and on her lips,
and I said, "I love you."
She said, "You never did that before.
"Where'd this come from?"
I said, "From a book that I read."
And it had meant something to me
and now it means something to her.
And it all came back full
circle last night when I went
to her house and I couldn't
greet her in that way
to show her.
Her birthday was September
and I had missed it
because I didn't have the money.
So what happened was when I
got to her place last night,
I said, "Look mom, I
have to run to the store
"to get a few things. I'll be right back."
I went to the Ralph's Supermarket.
It took me about 45 minutes
to find the right card,
but I found it and I presented it to her.
And she read it.
She said, "Put your mask on."
I put my mask on.
She just hugged me and held me.
(sighs)
And that's how I left her house, man,
and said, "I love you."
And words can't describe what
it feels like just to get
that feeling.
'Cause today, I'm not
on time for birthdays
and Christmases and
holidays and shit like that.
Sometimes, they're on, but
it's like hit and miss with me
'cause I have two left feet.
I'm like the little train that could.
I want to think I have,
a new life is good,
and I got my shit together,
but in all honesty, I don't, man.
It's trial and error.
Even dealing with my
family is hit and miss
because all of the times
that I was in prison,
all of the time, all the rehabs,
all of the trips, the bullshit,
just had me further and further away
from dealing with my loved ones.
Crack, everything,
I gave crack everything that I had.
My mind, my body, damn and my soul.
Family?
Shit, put them in a pipe and smoke them.
Relationships, I don't give a fuck.
Jobs? Man, that's shit.
You can't pay me to work.
Are you serious?
And last night just showed
me that there's a lot
of work ahead for me.
There's a lot of work ahead for me, man.
And I'd like to start off with, hey,
shit, man, I've been working
now for about three months
and I work in the construction field,
but my thing is under the table.
And why under the table?
Because that's the way
it turned out for me.
I was in jail, man, for about,
how long have I been home?
I've been home from
prison (counts silently)
May of 2017 and I was in the gym every day
from May 2017 up until
about eight months ago
before the COVID hit, COVID-19,
and they shut it down.
And the first time they shut it down, man,
I was depressed for about seven days.
I had withdrawals like I had
flu symptoms and I didn't eat,
I didn't sleep, I didn't drink water,
nothing for about four days.
Then three days after
that, still depressed.
It took me about a week and a half
to get through it.
And then they opened back up the gyms
and I was like hip, hip, hurray.
And I went for the next two weeks
and they shut it down again.
And I remember being in my room
and I was in bed and I was
just thinking to myself,
if something doesn't happen,
then mind, body, and spirit,
I just saw myself sinking in quicksand.
I just saw myself just sinking and sinking
without nobody being able to help,
to lend a hand down to get me up out that.
And that's what it felt like, man.
I said I can't go through what
I went through the first time
they shut it down, not eating, sleeping,
and being depressed, man.
It fucked me up.
Why?
The gym is my foundation.
I've been dealing with the
gym now for the past 30 years.
The gym helped me through my 20s,
it helped me through my 30s,
and it helped me through my 40s.
That's all I had, was my body,
my looks to get me through.
And it worked far as
relationships with women.
Women were attracted to the body,
the size, the look, and
that's what carried me, man.
It didn't help me stay out of prison,
it didn't help me stay out
of motherfucking rehabs,
it didn't help me keep from being homeless
over and over and over again.
But it worked with the
women, with the ladies.
And it only worked for so long
because as soon as the crack
start knocking on the door,
there I go.
And eventually, I put her in
a pipe and smoked her up too,
with the furniture, and
everything else that come with it,
the house, the car, all that bullshit.
'Cause after I take a hit,
everything is a crack coupon, man.
It's just a coupon.
Matter of time,
going out of business sale.
And that's just the way it was.
And so I'm in my room and
I'm thinking to myself,
I can't go through what I
went through the first time.
And creator, you have to
show me something, please.
That next day,
I got a phone call from
an old friend of mine.
He said, "Hey, would you like to work?"
And this happened to be the weekend.
I said, "Sure."
He came to my house and got me
and I've been working ever since.
It's going on four months.
I learned how to paint,
I learned how to lay cement,
and now I'm refurbishing
floors, wood floors.
And I work seven days a week
or six days a week now,
hit and miss, it all depends.
Now truth be told,
I'm not getting paid what
I'm supposed to be paid
because like I said,
I'm not certified, qualified,
and none of that shit,
but where I get paid is in the experience,
being taught something that
I've never been taught before.
Everything I'm learning in my 50s,
I should've had that shit
in my 20s, 30s, and 40s,
but see how I had to twist it?
I had the gym in my 20s, 30s, and 40s
and the only thing that
worked was the outside.
So it didn't give me that feeling
that I needed on the inside.
Because what I got from the
inside was everybody's approval,
everybody's accolades or the double-takes
and all that bullshit when
I'm walking down the street.
Oh, big man, hey, this, that.
That's what kept me going,
that's what kept me motivated,
that's what kept my ass in the gym,
everybody else's approval,
how they looked at me.
Flip side of the coin is when
I do a good job on the floor
and I see my work and my
boss come behind me say,
"Hey, man, that's a good job.
"You did good today, man.
"I'm proud of you."
Soon as I get my
motherfucking ass back home,
I cry like a baby.
I cry.
You know why?
'Cause every time I think about it,
it takes me back to when
I was 14, 15, 16 years old
and all the, (sighs)
and where I was at, at
that time of my life.
So emotionally, I feel,
I get that feeling of
being 15 years old or 16
when my boss say, "Hey,
man, you did a good job."
Or when something, when a light
goes on my mind and I say,
"Oh, I got it."
Then the feeling comes up
but not as a 53 years old
but as a 15-year-old emotionally.
That shit is crazy.
I still don't understand it.
I still don't get it.
There's a lot I don't get.
There's a lot that I missed
but it's okay.
It's okay.
Shit, there's some
questions that I might have
that I might never get an answer to,
but I'm okay with that.
I'm cool with that, shit.
(sighs)
Aside from working,
I'm just at a place, man,
where I'm learning how
to deal with me, be good
to me, treat myself,
take care of me, and everything
else that comes with it.
It's not easy me being on
my own, in my own place,
being responsible for me,
taking responsibility,
and all that because aside from me,
there's other people
that I have to deal with
and interact with.
And that bridge, man, that's a long bridge
that I have to cross, man.
Just to be like that
with my immediate family.
My brother's starting to come
around slowly but surely.
He might've saw one of the segments.
But he asked me some questions
and he came by the job site
and he said, "Hey, you
know there's some things
"you didn't know about me,
"but my hobbies are this and this."
And I looked, I said,
"Okay, I had no idea."
I'm like, "Man, I appreciate
you sharing that with me."
So that let me know.
That let me know something
that he's putting forth an effort.
I'm not looking for no,
(sighs)
(stammers)
I'm not looking for no apologies.
Nothing like that from the past, man.
It is what the fuck it is, man.
We've had our experiences
as growing up.
We never been close,
we never had no relationship,
we've never had no close bond.
I told him, man, I said, "You know what?
"You're a stranger to me.
"You're a brother just
in wording, in saying."
I said, "I don't know
anything pertinent about you.
"I don't know nothing important about you.
"I don't know your favorite color.
"I don't know your favorite foods.
"I don't know your hobbies.
"None of that."
You know?
I said, "We never did one
thing together growing up.
"We never went to the
football game together.
"We never played ball together.
"We never went to the
movies together, nothing."
One-on-one.
I said, "We have to
start off as strangers,
"work at being friends,
"and maybe one day we
can become brothers."
Because if we don't
start a strangers, man,
then there will always
be a misunderstanding.
There'll always be confusion.
It'd be like it was,
man, back in the days,
always bumping heads because
you're talking about,
oh you my little brother and all that,
you're my big brother,
but in actuality, man,
I've been gone 20-something
years off and on since the '80s.
All of them 20-some
trips, 19 trips to prison,
this two years, three
years, four years, nine,
when they do all that bullshit,
there's a lot we missed out on.
So me coming out in 2017,
I've been gone since 2011,
you want to pick up
right where we left off.
Shit.
Man, we got to start
from when we was kids.
'Cause there's a lot missing right there.
It ain't gray, it ain't no gray area.
Shit, it's a black area.
It's black and white.
Ain't no gray in between.
It's black, white, and then a gray.
Black is just total absence.
No communication, no nothing
from different points of time.
Different periods of time.
So every time I'm around
him, I feel like a stranger.
The only one I'm close to is my mother.
Why?
Because she wrote me all the trips,
all the 19 trips to prison.
She wrote me and stayed
in contact with me.
That's how I was able to build
that relationship with her.
It stayed like that with her,
those 19 motherfucking trips.
But she filled me in on how my family,
my siblings was doing.
Oh Tracy's doing this, Todd's doing this,
Chris is doing that, Isaiah.
So I'm looking at them through her eyes,
through her experience,
but I have to have my
own experience with them
to get the full picture.
I can't walk in nobody else's shoes
or nobody else's experience.
It can guide me.
I've got to walk with my own shoes,
have my own experiences
with Isaiah, Christopher, Todd, Tracy.
I've been home what? (stammers)
Three years.
And I'm no closer to
building a relationship
with none of them except my mama.
I'm working on it
but I'm a work in progress, man.
And the cool thing about it is
everybody have a
motherfucking life to live,
everybody's doing their thing.
And everybody's dealing with something.
But everybody's above water,
so I'm cool with that.
I'm cool with that.
It's gonna take some time.
Time might not be on my
side, it might, I don't know.
Shit.
I'm not no fortune teller.
But family,
it's a mystery.
Job, I'm learning.
But one thing about
work is I like working.
I like hard work, you know?
Shit.
Saturdays and Sunday, I do concrete.
I cement this woman's yard.
She wants to make it into a parking lot,
excuse me, a parking area,
so her kids, her two sons
can park their vehicles
on the property instead of on the streets
'cause it get kind of crowded.
And, man, doing an eight-hour day,
I might lift about 75, 80,
60-pound bags of cement,
take them to a designated
area where the mixer is,
open them up and pour them into the mixer.
Man, by the time I'm finished,
it feels like I had worked out
in the gym like three hours.
So in essence,
seven days a week, six
days a week, (stammers)
I'm in the gym.
But it's a different workout,
it's a different way.
And I feel it in different areas.
I don't feel it in my chest,
my arms, my shoulders,
my back, my legs,
but I do, but just it's
a different feeling.
And most importantly,
this kind of workout,
it helps me from the inside out.
It starts in my inner,
that self-esteem, that self-worth.
It gives me, it builds character, shit.
And what I'm being taught,
nobody can take away from me.
And everything I'm being
taught is the right way
how to do some shit.
I know the right way how to lay cement.
I know the right way how to paint.
I know the right way how to do a floor.
So my teachers, the men
that are in my life,
the three men that I'm dealing with,
they're giving me the right information,
the right tools to succeed
in these three areas,
which enables me to succeed in life.
Now I have to work on
dealing with my family
in that area because
it hasn't transformed.
It haven't manifested in that area yet.
But if I can just stay on
the straight and narrow
and get these experiences
from these different jobs
that I'm doing and learn them,
then it'll roll over into different areas.
I think (sighs)
it took me three days
to learn how to paint real good.
I mean, for real, for real.
It took me three days.
It took me about two
weeks how to do the cement
and about one week how to
work how to work the floor.
And I wish it was like
that with my family.
I wish it was like that with life.
But it's not, man, it's not.
I still have two left feet.
It's easy for my ass to trip.
I have to be careful, always.
There's not a day that I can let up.
There's not a day, man,
that I can just
wake up in the morning
and think to myself,
"Oh, today I'm just going to bullshit,
"lay around and do nothing."
I'm not gonna pray, I'm not
gonna meditate, (stammers)
I'm gonna just say F it, you know?
And when I think about those days,
I'll know right where I ended up,
in prison, in a crack house on the side
of the motherfucking freeway off ramp.
And I don't want that today.
I want something more than that.
I deserve more than that.
I owe myself more than that.
Shit, life is scary.
'Cause I've escaped.
I've been running for so
long, ran over 30 years.
And all of a sudden, I
got almost three years
of dealing with some shit.
And at the time, I didn't
want to deal with it.
Up until they shut down the gyms.
Then my foundation was crushed
because that was my
foundation, the gym, my body,
how I looked.
That's all I had.
That's all I had to offer
to the world as I know it.
But lo and behold, there was
more to me than I even knew.
I didn't believe enough.
I couldn't even see it what I see now.
But the cool thing about it is
instead of seeing some shit,
I'm living some shit.
That's the difference.
I'm living it.
Living my motherfucking dream.
What's that?
Doing the things I never thought I'd do.
Doing shit I was supposed
to do my 20s, 30s, and 40s.
Doing that shit in 50s.
That's one of those unspoken
prayers that's being answered.
Shit.
It ain't easy.
But it's okay, it's okay.
Never thought I'd be here.
Never thought I'd be in
his position, this place,
mind, body, and spirit.
When I wake up in the morning
and the first thing I think
about is being on time.
How hard I'm gonna do today.
What I'm gonna do.
And when I get there, put
forth the effort, man.
Do the best that I can do
throughout the day, man.
And that's it.
And when I'm coming back,
you know the cool thing
about it is when I leave,
instead of getting picked up by my boss,
I catch the bus and train to the job site
just so I have time just to
relax and get my mind together,
to deal with whatever day has in store.
It's the same when I
get finished with work.
I have my boss take me
to the train station
or the bus station, (stammers)
so I have time just to unwind
from what I experienced
and just let it, let
it marinate, you know?
And by the time I get home, I'm good.
I'm with me.
With me.
It ain't about them,
it ain't about the double-takes
when motherfuckers look,
it ain't about that no more.
I don't even trip on that.
I'm not even,
I haven't been in a relationship
in about nine months.
I'm not on the bus and
trains looking at people
and trying to get at the women.
I admire them.
I love them.
I love them all.
I love women.
Shit, I ain't tripping on that.
But the point is,
I'm not out there
trying to get in no relationship
or nothing like that, man.
I'm just out and dealing with life,
enjoying it for what it is, man.
And when it's the right time,
God's gonna put her in my life.
I'm not worried about that.
But my thing is everything
that I thought would
make me happy, it was
all from the outside.
But what really makes me
happy is having the courage
to get up and face another
day, come what may.
That's it, man.
In a nutshell.
There's so much I want,
but what I really need is to keep doing
what the fuck I'm doing,
staying in my lane and out the way.
Shit.
I want everything.
I want it all.
But I'm gonna get me what
I need just to make it
through the day.
And that's enough for me, man.
That's enough for me.
There's so much more that I can talk about
when it comes to being home, being free,
and trying to navigate life on like terms,
not on my terms.
If it was on my terms, I have a car,
I have a two-bedroom apartment,
I'd be in a relationship,
have kids, a motorboat, mobile home.
I have the merry-go-round
in the back of the yard
and all that bullshit,
10 kids running around.
But in reality, all I got is me.
And I have to depend on me, love on me,
and treat me and all that bullshit, man.
And sometimes it,
(stammers)
(sighs)
it's scary, to be honest with you.
(stammers)
'Cause I'm by myself, I'm
alone, and I have to do this.
I have some assistance.
I get suggestions and stuff like that.
But when it's all said and done,
I have to put one foot in front
of the motherfucking other.
I don't give a fuck if
somebody take me by the hand
and just guide me.
I still got to do it.
I still got to do my part
and that's what's scary.
It's scary but at the same time,
it gives me the freedom to go
where I've never gone before,
to be who I never thought I'd become.
I wouldn't trade it for nothing else.
And like I said,
there's so much more
I can talk about, man,
but the bottom line is,
(sighs)
I only get one chance at this.
And,
(sighs)
it's about time that I showed up.
And I'm just glad, man,
that I have the opportunity
to put my money where my mouth is.
So today I let my actions
speak louder than my words.
I talk a good one but I
can show you some shit
I learned today and my work is good.
Yeah.
Bet your last dollar.
You can take that
motherfucking check to the bank
and cash it.
I've got something to offer today
and it ain't my body, it ain't my looks.
I've got some real
skills to pay the bills.
Holler.
Thank you.